we're gonna
pick up where we left off on monday
and where we left off was we were
dissolving stuff we talked about how
things
dissolve why does something dissolve
maybe in this solvent versus that and
how does it dissolve and what makes them
and then we say well what if we had
something and we wanted it to dissolve
all the way until it couldn't dissolve
anymore well that's called
saturation right
and and we talked about that we talked
about how if you had a general reaction
you know maybe we had something like
this right a
a plus b b
goes to and comes back from
c c plus dd then
this reaction can happen in both ways
right and so the general
concept that we called a reaction
quotient
reaction q
is equal to remember it's equal to the
concentrations
raised to those stoichiometric
coefficients
and it's the products over
the reactants okay so that's what we now
then we
we say well okay that's just okay that's
a thing that that has to do with sort of
maybe
you know where's that reaction going
what's dominating
uh it and these came remember these are
the stoichiometric coefficients and
they're related to
literally like the probability that that
reaction can happen
okay um and so if you want an intuitive
reason for the exponents you can think
about this as well if these all have to
get close enough in a given volume
to react then that's where those
exponents come from
but they don't but unlike the rate law
when i said this money i'm saying it
again say they are not things that are
experimentally measured instead they
just come
from the reaction itself okay now uh so
we're just getting back into the right
mood here but then we said well but look
okay this thing is reacting it's going
back and forth
whatever but what about once it reaches
equilibrium right equilibrium and and
when it reaches equilibrium
it's the same thing but we call it k
eq in
equilibrium equal m
equilibrium right so so that reaction
quotient
has a very specific value a constant
a constant once this way
is happening in the same amount as that
way
right that's the saturation point
well if you're dissolving something
that's the saturation point
okay so it's where it's where the
precipitation remember we wrote this as
dissolution and precipitation when we
were putting stuff in solution and
that's kind of where we got to
we went a little bit further and we had
a specific example and that's where i
want to start today
and that's silver chloride okay so here
we go so we have
silver chloride and if i write this all
out for silver chloride i've got
a g cl and i've got a little pinch of it
you know like a little speck of silver
chloride i'm putting it into
a beaker so it starts out as a solid and
i add some water to it
and the water is l because it's
everywhere it's the liquid it's the
solvent
okay it's the liquid that i'm dissolving
it in and we say well okay
that's going to go like this so that
reaction it's going to give us
silver ions remember salts we did salts
and chlorine ions and
back to some more water
okay that's h2o now the aq means aqueous
these are now
because it's a salt right these are now
dissolved ions because it's a salt so we
write them like that
and we know we got water everywhere and
so oftentimes we leave the water out
oftentimes we don't really write the
water because it's on both sides
and anyway we don't the water the water
is just surrounding stuff it's not
necessarily been consumed
the concentration of the water isn't
changing
the water is the water in the liquid
phase
well okay then we went even further you
said well if you write a keq for this
then it would uh i would look like
something like okay it's the
concentration of silver plus
in solution times the concentration of
chlorine
minus in solution and that would be
divided by
the concentration of silver chloride
as a solid and then we said
but hold on no but hold on
in the solid phase the concentration
isn't changing
right as a solid silver chloride the
concentration of silver chloride is
silver chloride it's a constant
and so then we say well okay if this
is a constant this is a constant
then we can also absorb it into the
equilibrium constant
and i somewhat confusingly wrote it as
ksp in both
this form and the form that
we know and love for ksp which is simply
literally the solubilities of these
times each other right and that is ksp
so i wanted just to clarify this
because the student asked a very good
question which is
which is which is it now is this in ks
p or is this in keq well the the the big
full picture for keq
you know you'd write it all in but the
solubility product
is focusing in right on on the the
dissolution
of these ions and and so you wrap this
into the equilibrium constant because
it's another constant so that's the
solubility product and that's where we
got
to on monday the solubility product is a
special equilibrium constant
where what we're talking about right
is is you know what what are the
concentrations when you've reached
saturation of this dissolution
precipitation reaction
okay that's the solubility product
that's ksp
so you wrap this in and you get you get
your ksp
uh you can think about it as well maybe
you could have called this some ksp
in you know uh uh pre-ksp and then you
wrap this in and then it's still just
kidding
because it's still just a constant
representing this reaction okay i just
wanted to make this super clear because
this
part leads to confusion often that this
gets left
out because it's constant doesn't change
okay
good now we get to that because
this is a constant okay so what does
that mean
well it means that if i dissolve this
thing in water
right then then the equilibrium the
equilibrium
is is a fixed number this equilibrium
product is fixed
and that has a very important meaning
it's the green curve
you see it says equilibrium right and
and so
that what that means is that if i you
know if i'm at point b well there i go
i've got my we we said ksp
ksp for this one equals
uh what was it 1.7
times 10 to the minus 10th
units are coming and so now so that's
the ksp
for uh for
silver chloride
in h2o oh and you have to say
at some temperature
it will depend on temperature often you
often will just
be at room temperature 25 c for example
so often these get quoted just at room
temperature
okay now okay so once i know that then i
know that that's equilibrium no matter
what
right and so that means that if like you
know and then we solve this we said well
okay if i dissolve silver chloride
and i didn't and i had nothing else then
you know the ksp would equal
the concentration of silver times the
concentration of chlorine ions
and so if we let each one but those are
equal and so if we let each one of them
be x then it's equal to x squared
and so we know that the concentration of
each of them
is 10 to the minus
let me write it exactly 1.3 times 10
to the minus fifth now it's a
concentration so you know
that it's got to be capital m moles per
liter
and and since that's the case since
that's where you know
what it is then now you can back up
because this is the concentration
of ag ions and it's also the
concentration of chlorine ions
then you know that the the units of ksp
must be m squared right
units in this case
moles per liter square must be because
otherwise the concentration isn't right
the units are concentration okay now now
okay now we're going to play with this
so okay so i'm at b i'm at point b
you see that there i am and i've got my
concentration of chlorine
concentration of silver and i'm here and
and so that's 1.3 times 10 to minus 5th
okay now if i if i didn't have as much
if i didn't if i weren't at the
saturation point
right then i could add more i'd be here
and i could add more solid silver
chloride and i didn't you know and
eventually i'd reach this uh
i'd reach this this equilibrium but if i
added more than that
so now i'm adding way more than i can
then it's just going to be a solid
and that's kind of boring so now i'm up
here
but maybe i had ions in so these are the
ions so maybe i add a whole bunch of
ions well they're just going to
precipitate i can't be here
and be in equilibrium that's the point
of the green curve this k
doesn't change this k is is this k
that's what the green curve is it is
that being constant
that's very important that is
equilibrium now
there is a way though to move around on
it
yeah because if i did imagine now look
at point c
now imagine now that i've i've found
some source of chlorine ions
and i add a whole bunch of them
right a whole bunch of them into this
solution i don't add silver
and chlorine together i just add
chlorine well you can see what's going
to happen
i have to get to equilibrium and so in
order to stay
in equilibrium for silver chloride in
solution then
i must lower my concentration of silver
because i added all this chlorine right
well the only way to do that
is to eat up some silver and precipitate
that's the only way to do that and that
has a name
and that's what i want to talk about
next that is called
the common ion effect
now this is an example this
is an example of a broader principle
which is which i mentioned monday which
is le chatelier's principle
okay
and that is that position of
position of equilibrium
will move it's still equilibrium but
it's moving
on that green curve right to counteract
change
this is a very uh
general principle it applies to many
many things it's
done not just concentrations it applies
to changes in pressure
and other changes that you can make in a
system here we care about concentration
and in this particular case we're going
to see it for what happens when you add
ions right of one particular type
and not the other that's the common ion
effect
but it's a very general effect that it
resists the change
now let's see how that works
my if i um if i want a source of ions
let's say i want a source of chlorine
one way would be to add a whole bunch of
sodium chloride
right so let's suppose that i have
um okay so i'm going to add
as an example i'm going to add
to this nice equilibrium that i reached
here so i'm at point b
okay and i'm going to add
0.1 mol
moles per liter of sodium chloride
and this nearly
and so we're going to say it does it
nearly fully dissociates
and we'll be talking about that later
today and so that means that that this
goes nacl
basically goes to na plus plus cl minus
both in solution so if i put point
if i put 0.1 moles per liter of sodium
chloride into this
into this uh container of the silver
chloride
i'm basically going to get point one
because of the stoichiometric
coefficient
one one one right yeah so if i put .1
moles per liter of this i'm going to
have
0.1 moles per liter of chlorine ions
that i just dumped into the container
but the sodium doesn't it the sodium is
not going to do anything
but it's just look at the chlorine
that's going to mess
with my equilibrium but k
is a constant so let's see what happens
we can do it
we can do it visually but we can also do
it back when we use the ice table
right so so now we're going to go ice
again a g
c l and here's uh
a g plus okay and here's
c l minus so now i've added the okay so
my initial
is that this is solid remember it's it's
this is the
the solid of the that i'm putting in
there and then i
i started my initial is that i started
in that nice equilibrium at point b
so i've got 1.3 times 10 to the minus
fifth
and over here i've got the same
but now the change now the change
we're gonna add okay so we're gonna add
some chlorine ions 0.1
so i've added 0.1 moles per liter of
chlorine ions from the salt
from sodium chloride yeah but now some
of that is going to
react because as i just said le
chatelier's principle tells me that now
there's it's got to counter that and you
can see it right here too
i'm adding a whole bunch of chlorine so
i'm going look at how far i'm going out
point one that's like literally all the
way out to here
and so and so the amount of silver has
got to go down
and what's going to happen is it's going
to consume
some of the silver and form precipitate
to counter
all this addition it's going to run the
reaction the other way
so it's going to lose a little bit there
from the point 1 that's going to react
with
the silver ions so that's going to also
lose and this is going to gain
that's how much that's going to get so
those are the variables right this is
the ice table
that's how much how much it's going to
look these are going to react
to give me some precipitate and so the
equilibrium
is more okay more solid
forms that's not a good e
more solid forms and over here it's 1.3
times 10 to the minus fifth minus x
and over here it's 0.1 minus x
that's the equilibrium condition i've
added in a common ion this is the common
ion effect
and so now if you do the math
then what happens
well again ksp
is the same it's the equilibrium
constant so it's the constant
so that is going to be the same value
it's going to be 1.7
times 10 to the minus 10th but you see
ksp
is also equal to the concentration in
equilibrium
of the silver ions times the
concentration of the chlorine ion so
it's going to be
0.1 minus x times 1.3
times 10 to the fifth minus x
and then we don't like doing all this
math and so we simplify
then we can simplify because look
you started with silver ions in a very
small concentration
x can't be you can't take away something
you don't have
right and and so x has got to be somehow
this or less right and so x is a small
number
and this is a really big number in
comparison
and so we like simplifying our lives
right
and so we we like saying that that's
like point one
we know that that'll make the math a lot
easier right
that'll make the math a lot easier and
so
now we can say that this is equal to
uh okay 0.1
times 1.3 times 10 to the minus fifth
minus x and then we get that x
equals 1.7 times 10 to the minus ninth
that is the common ion effect what i've
done i've taken this thing in
equilibrium and i've added one of the
ions
right and and and it changes the
solubility remember the solubility is
what we care about
that's what the solubility product the
solubility constant helps us determine
and i've literally just changed it by
orders of magnitude
right because now the the amount that
this
so this thing precipitates like crazy i
added in a little bit of some other ion
that some other salt that had
chlorinitis and all of a sudden silver
chloride precipitates out
right so here's a video of that so this
is kind of cool so watch this is a
an equilibrium container and what i'm
adding is salt
and look at that what is that that's
silver chloride precipitate
right because the thing has to reach
equilibrium
and so in order to do so what you do is
you
you suppress the solubility you
literally by adding chlorine the common
ion effect
you suppress the solubility of the
silver chloride right
it's pretty cool stuff that is the
common ion effect now why does this
matter
oh let me give you one i'll get to why
this matters in a second
one more question so you can now without
even doing the math
check this one out this is cool without
even
without even doing the math i can take
barium sulfate
okay and from this from the common ion
effect so barium sulfate
is going to go so what does that one
look like well it's going to go to be a
two plus plus so4
two minus both in solution in solution
dissolved ions this is a solid
now which here's the question
which of the following will be required
in the least amount to dissolve
the same amount of ba so4
i don't need any constants or math i can
use the same principle because
if i had some 0.1 molar or 0.01
moles per liter of either of these what
are they doing
they're serving up ions right in the one
case
you're serving up in one case you're
serving up
so in case a you're going to give me
what do i have there h2so4
so let's do a first h2so4
is going to give me a whole bunch of h
plus
but also so4 2 minus and
in case b you have
uh bacl okay so you have ba
cl2 and if i put that in i've got this
in water
right but if i put but if this dissolves
in water a little bit then it's going to
serve up
some ba 2 plus plus
2 cl minus
either way now you know what's going to
happen
because if i'm trying to dissolve
something
and i add any of the ions
that it's dissolving into from some
external source
it's going to drive it this way it's
going to precipitate
right so the answer has to be just water
stick with pure water in this case
otherwise you're gonna
you're gonna have more trouble
dissolving just like we just showed
you're gonna have more trouble
dissolving not less that's the common
ion effect
all right now why okay so now why does
this matter
why does this matter oh we go back to
the terror pot
and by the way i didn't have this link
and i should have when i showed you the
the and this is your goody bag etc right
there's some really nice uh articles
here that you can find related to these
experiments and other things about ocean
acidity
and uh in case you're interested um but
see
what we what i did is was that this was
my why this matters on monday
and i wanted to tell you about the
goodie bag and about
the how things dissolve because monday
was about
dissolving right and finding a
saturation point
now we can we can get to the next place
which is
why does that matter for the terrapot
shell
what is the chemistry that that matters
there
okay so i made the ocean a little more
acidic
why does that matter but you see now
we're armed with the knowledge we need
to answer that question
now we're armed with it all we need to
do as always with everything in life
is look at the chemistry that's it
say that at the thanksgiving table
you'll be very popular
we said co2 plus h2o
this goes oh
it finds some equilibrium 2h2
co3 now this is called carbonic acid
this is called carbonic acid there's the
pteropod up there
and there's a reaction that's that's
really relevant that you'll see from the
ones we're about to write down why
because the thing is that why what
happens to carbonic acid
that well carbonic acid also goes
through
a dissolution reaction so carbonic acid
so this is co2
dissolving in water now we make carbon
so carbonic acid
uh goes like this okay
it goes into h co three minus
plus h plus
now here's the thing okay what is the
shell made of
well the shell that's dissolving in
in its you know kind of like the core
material is calcium carbonate
so that's caco3
that's the shell and the shell also has
an equilibrium reaction that happens
the shell of of of a c a creature is in
dynamic equilibrium with the ocean
and and so it's going like this it's
going to uh well okay
c a two plus and
c o three two minus and
and and okay but the thing is it has an
equilibrium constant all these have
equilibrium constants
so like for example for this one the k
sp
the solubility product constant because
this is a solid this is a solid shell
solid going to ions in aqueous solution
but so the ksp for that is somewhere
around 5
times 10 to the minus 9.
5 times 10 to the minus 9. yeah but
here's the thing we just went through
this
if i consume one of these or change the
concentration of
one of these and not the other
we just did this if i if i change the
concentration if i consume
any of these then i might drive the
reaction
consume or produce if i change any of
these
independently i'm going to drive the
reaction because that's
how we keep to our k that's what le
chatelier's principle tells us
and so what ends up happening is you've
got
the extra h
plus ions so these are ions in solution
where did they come from they came from
the co2 giving us
carbonic acid which then gave us h plus
those are what i'm talking about
well they react
with the co3 minus
3032 minus
this lowers the co32 minus concentration
near the shell right because then tight
and if i lower this because i've taken
some of this now and i've reacted it
so now i've got less of it and because
of what we just saw if i've got less of
this you're going to drive
this way which is going to dissolve
more of the shell right that's why this
works
that's why this this happens
works sounds like a positive thing right
so this lowers
the concentration of co32 minus
and that drives
more dissolution
that is what's happening and we now can
understand it in terms of the concepts
that we've just learned
historically i mentioned 50 million
years actually by some accounts it's 300
million
it depends on which studies you read
but but for at least 50 and maybe as
much as 300 million years the ocean
uh has had a ph of 8.18
now where's the oh yeah right
so let's just say you know
last 0 50 to 300 million
ish years
the ocean ph
was 8.18 and today
it's 8.07
and the prediction is that in 2100
it will be 7.8
now as we will see in a little bit and
he said what's ph
well many of you probably already know
but we i will tell you what it is in a
little bit
but because this is a logarithmic thing
this is a lot
right today the ocean is 25 percent more
acidic than it's been in 300 million
ish years and in 2100 it will be 126
percent
more acidic that's why they used 7.8 in
in the experiments of the pteropots okay
okay right
why does this happen why is this
molecule
an acid we're talking about
acidification of oceans
why is this an acid in the first place
what does it mean to be an acid and that
is the next topic
that is what i want to talk about next
why what is an acid
and an acid is something that is very
specific it has a very definite
meaning to it and i want to talk about
that today
and then we'll continue after the break
right so
this molecule carbonic acid is called an
acid
because of that proton and you could
feel it
right you could feel it in this in this
whole thing the proton is the part is
the thing that did the
cause the problem right an acid
this is an acid because of the proton so
an acid is it's it's a dissolution
reaction
dissolution it's what we've been talking
about it's a dissolution
reaction that
gives an h plus
and so now if i think about it as kind
of a generic case
generic acid a
then the reaction looks something like
this
i'm going to call out the acid and the
proton that it gives
separately right okay so this is h a so
we do this because it highlights
that it's an acid h plus
in solution and these can all be in
solution
plus a minus in solution
right h plus a minus
right so i've taken a proton off you see
it's right there
that's that's h a h a where a
is hco3 and h is h and then what i've
done is i've transferred
the proton into solution that's an acid
now
um the thing is one of the things now
you will see
a lot of of places and people writing h
plus and we will do that too because so
many textbooks use h plus
but the thing is that h plus what i want
you to know
is that h plus is never a thing
we just write it that way h plus is not
stable in water
so the the proper
the proper way to write this general
reaction would be h
a plus h2o
okay is going to go to and now i'm going
to write the full
right so the fold goes both ways is
going to go to h3
o plus plus a minus goes in tight
this is what happens because h plus is
not stable in water but you will see h
plus written all over the place
when you see h plus and if it's in water
know
that it's h3o plus that is what is
stable
okay h plus in water is not
now there's something here that's
important in terms of terminology
and that is that these are notice that
these are related
right the h a and the a minus seem very
related and the h2o and the h2o
h3o plus seem very related well they are
because they're just
a proton is the only difference between
them and so those are called conjugate
pairs
conjugate related conjugate pairs
okay those are called conjugate pairs
now back in the day there was a lot of
interest people knew about
these kind of liquids
mostly liquids for a long time and there
was a lot of experimentation before this
let's say well there's these general
classes of materials
we're going to call them a and b well a
seems to always taste kind of sour
b is bitter a reacts with carbonates
to make co2 b reacts with fats and soap
to make soaps
all right one reacts with metals the
other doesn't and by the way if we mix
them together we seem to always get salt
and water
this had been going on for centuries
this investigation
into properties of acids and bases
but who was it that came along who was
it that came along
svante is there anything you can't do
svonte
i ask you again in the late 1800s
it was svonte to the rescue
who first proposed that what is
happening here
is a dissolution reaction that is what
an acid or base is
it is that in on the one hand you're
given an h plus
which is what i just said
but on the other hand
for a base you're given an oh minus and
it was fonte arenas
who first put that down and first
conceived of acids and
are we snapping are we quiet snapping
for sponte i love it
i've just recently learned what that
means it makes me happy
quiet snapping it's instead of clapping
but you don't want to make noise but you
still want to give props i got it
i'm there i'm right there now okay so uh
okay
now here's the thing so we'll talk about
so uh okay arrhenius says
bases give oh ions in solution and
oh acids give h plus but we know that
that's h3o plus
okay we know that okay
yeah but the thing is there's a
dissolution reactions
these things lead to really small
concentrations
and so soren sorensen
that is a beer bottle by the way his
research was funded by a beer company
yeah and it was all about the taste of
beer
he called it looking at proteins
but it was about beer and what he
realized he's
doing all these dissolution reactions of
ions i think iranians was right yeah
ions are really important
uh and we're trying to measure these
things and but i'm sick of all these
zeroes
i don't like writing .0001 or whatever
all the time and and so look at that
1.3 times 10 to the minus fifth that's
not efficient
and so what sorensen did is he talked
about how
you've got the power now what do i mean
by power
so many things right but if i look at h
plus okay h3o plus
and i say let's suppose the
concentration is 0.0
oh boy zero zero zero zero one
that's ten to the minus seventh
because but but sorensen wasn't happy
with that that's still
you simplified it wait two four no it's
not
okay maybe it is now
and he said well i ten to the minus
seven there's still four characters i
gotta write
four so he went to the math department
at his place and he said how do you what
else could me
i want to talk about the power of these
ions and they're like
power well that's the logarithm
and and so if you take the log it's the
power of hydrogen
power of hydrogen
is the ph and that's simply minus the
law
they didn't want negative numbers either
oh but you can't have negative ph
you can why because this is the
definition
of ph right or you could do poh since
if you're going with arrhenius right so
the power of
hydrogen is the ph the poh would be
minus log
of the concentration of o h minus
that's the poh but ph is the one that we
most
often see to describe
whether something is acidic or basic
right and so now you see well if the you
know okay well this is a ph
now this is easy right it's a ph of
seven and and if the concentration were
like
point one it'd be a ph of one right
minus
log the power of hydrogen the law
literally the log
okay now if you look at scales of ph and
it's a really fun thing to do
then what you find is that usually
almost always actually you'll see the
scale ranging from 0 to 14.
that's what sorensen originally decided
i'm going to talk about these ions in
solution
i don't want to write it out every time
i'm just going to have a simple scale
we'll take the minus log and there you
go yeah but
you can see that if the if the
concentration is more than one here
then you could have negative ph's
there's nothing special about zero here
it just so happens that most things
certainly that he was playing with at
the time
were in this scale and here's a few
things that we know
there it is right okay don't play with
that one but play with lemon juice
vinegar
by the way vinegar okay wine is around
three and a half
vinegar is around two you know
then the the word vinegar is
von egar it's eager wine
that's it right and but and it comes
it's because of the the acidity
the acidity well it's more than that but
it's the acidity is changing
by orders of magnitude power
right and then you can go back and you
say okay there's coffee i like that a
lot and
and blood
by the way by the way talk about ocean
acidity
blood has a very narrow range of ph
and if you change the ph of your blood
by more than 0.2
it is very likely to lead to death right
so just think about that's what we're
doing to the ocean
okay anyway that was an aside
seawater oh ph 8.07 currently and
dropping
right uh okay baking soda so this is a
very powerful no pun intended actually
um
uh now these are dissociation reactions
these are dissolution reactions i'm
taking an acid
and i'm dissociating it in water
and so you have equilibrium constants
for that dissociation
right and so and so if you if you go
back to
to that you know that's still going to
matter here and that's
going to be important in thinking about
what an acid is because again why is it
sick well because there's these protons
well how many of them are there
it depends on how it dissolved where did
it find
its equilibrium right and so for some of
them like i just wrote
you know we we just talked about
hcl plus uh
h2o that went to uh
h3o plus plus
uh cl minus okay now
the thing is if i had if i had 0.1
moles per liter of hcl then
it's going to lead to a concentration of
h3o plus
of around 0.1 moles per liter because
it's
nearly full nearly
full dissociation
what is what do i mean by that well i
mean that yeah okay you know so you'll
often see for
like an acid like that one arrow
well we know that in reality there's
another arrow there
but see here the acid dissociation
constant
is huge right so now we have a thing for
the equilibrium
of an acid which forms by dissociating
the acid
into its you know ions right and this
is well for in this case it's 10 to the
sixth
it's enormous which means that the
equilibrium lies
very very very very far over and so
oftentimes you'll see
if it's going to strongly dissociate
like sodium chloride did
right then you'll sometimes see it
written as just one arrow
but there's a little bit going back as
well right
that is another equilibrium constant and
we will talk about ka
a little later and probably pick up on
it next week
okay now so near fold associated now
the other thing that can happen that's
important
is water can do both and so there's
there's uh let's see where should i go
i'll go back over here
so water
see that picture there they got it wrong
but it's okay they got it right because
we all get along
if you want to put h plus fine but you
know that it's actually h3o plus okay
good but you can put h plus no problem
okay um now there it
is and you can see that what water can
do is it can do both
and that turns out to be extremely
important so if i take water
and i mix it with water
then you can get a combination of
these ions
oh plus a whole bunch of water
so this would be like dissociation now
there's a word for this
water can turn into either
it can it can be basic or acidic it can
it can deliver o h minus
or h3o plus right that's called auto
ionization
and it also has a special word water is
called amphoteric
amphoteric now that means
that the same thing
can be both
both acid
or a base
it can act as either now so if you take
pure water so let's see
if i take pure water and
oh
and i look at the concentrations of
these
uh so atrial plus it's all happening
from the water there's nothing in it i
didn't add anything to it
it's just pure water acetyl plus so that
means that
you know if that reaction happens it's
going to generate
you know the same number so the h3o plus
would equal the concentration of the o h
minus
and in pure water that is a value
that is equal to 1 times 10 to the minus
7th
moles per liter at
25c okay
at 25c and so now we have yet another
that's neutral you can understand that
that's neutral
because because it you have the
same you know if an acid is h plus or
h3o plus in solution and a base is o h
minus
and i've made the same number right
uh then they neutralize the acidity and
basicity are neutralizing one another so
that's neutral
and in fact you can see that that's uh
ph
is seven oh and we can even write the
equilibrium constant for water
which is going to be those guys h3o
minus times uh atrial plus times oh
minus
which is equal to 10 to the negative
14th
right because that's the dissociation
reaction for water water plus water goes
to those ions in solution
we ignore the water right and then we're
left with this
same thing we've been doing okay 10 to
the minus 14.
now that takes us we neutral you know
those are neutral
and and and so speaking of of neutral
that's where we're going to go next and
uh
i think what i want to do now is you
know
so we're going to go next into
neutralizing things
so like if you add an acid to a base or
if you had a bastion acid
and and we already said on monday you
get salt and water um
but see to understand that you need a
different you need a broader definition
cevante is amazing
but zevante missed something and and so
we need
a different definition of acids and
bases that's more general
and that's what we're going to start
with on monday but wait because
this is a great place for me to work on
my arm
i gotta hit okay
we're gonna go all the way up there and
all the way up there
and right there and right there and
oh there and there and there
and there oh that was excitement
let's go back there in there okay
and there oh that was the same direction
there
and there and there in the middle
and there and there oh
that was there and there
and there and
you guys are seeing i need i need a
stronger arm here
i can't really get too far and uh
and oh that side is all in there
and there and there
and one more i'm going deep
have a great thanksgiving everyone
see you guys on monday
you